it's great to welcome to the program
today Zenta brice who is a soviet born
journalist and author currently living
in france she's recently published her
first book in english called eagle in
the fridge about the end of the Cold War
era when the Soviet Union ultimately did
fall apart
Zenda it's so interesting to speak to
you you know personally I've read so
much historical fiction that centers
around the last years of the former of
the Cold War era and the Soviet Union
but we never know whether we're really
getting an accurate picture of what it
was like to live in the former Soviet
Union at that time so I guess let me
generally open up the floor to you to
tell us a little bit of what you think
is usually missing from a Western
understanding of living in the former
Soviet Union about so it Union written
by Westerners my vision about is it's
Outsiders it's always also to sue
because we all have stereotypes and cold
war-era create the stereotypes both ways
from the Soviet Union to the West and
they were good stereotypes and they were
bad stereotypes and the same happened
from the west to the east so when a
westerner looks it's always this one
United Soviet Union a conglomerate of
people the gray dark green faces and all
that but it's not what it was one thing
which for this book is very important I
think is we must remember that Soviet
Union was a very big country and very
variable country with a lot of diversity
this book tells the story from the
Baltic from the western end of of Soviet
Union if you if the same story would be
written somewhere in Casa
for example today it would be completely
different point of view with different
traditions different culture diversity
was huge and it's not religious solids
it's basically imagine today's refugee
refugees coming out from Syria and then
sitting in in New York that was the
difference between let's say West and
East part of a Soviet Union so my point
of in this book is just one way this one
little bit its Western is Baltic States
it's Latvia but it's happening when we
think about day to day life in the last
years of the Soviet Union and we think
about the sort of caricatures and
stereotypes that often exists in the
West in terms of you know empty grocery
stores and lines for the most basic food
supplies etc how much of that portrayal
is accurate absolutely that's absolutely
correct because it's how it happened but
we must point out that we were not
exactly starving and empty grocery shop
didn't means that we are starving
because it was witches are also
portrayed in the book it was something
similar we would call a black market it
was exchange car mechanic exchange with
a butcher services to the procas it
simply the main problem was money had no
value because the last years so it's
worth printing more and more and more
money probably for the Westerner it's
rather hard to realize that you have
purse full of money and no goods to buy
and for me that was the biggest shock
when we turns out the cars and become a
Western country suddenly you have plenty
of goods but no money right
I'm guessing Zenta that this varied and
again you know in your book Eagle in the
fridge you're talking about
aspect of the soviet union talking about
latvia can you talk a little bit about
media freedom law enforcement sort of
independence and morality courts etc
some of these issues that when you
evaluate a country the way that for
example the Human Rights World Report
might evaluate a country what was the
situation in the Soviet Union when it
came to political dissidents media
freedom etc media freedom up to eighty
seven eighty eight in some parts eighty
nine was non-existent simply forget it's
not such thing as media freedom
I think the Baltic states first started
87 when a little bit of realistic
information see so it made it was was
full of propaganda
it was just propaganda and nothing else
first first sign of freedom was when
private had started to appear like
marriages apartment exchanges private
little sales or something it was the
first song the MIDI is getting a bit
more before it was always how much
harvested the heroic of farmers heroic
ooh heavy machinery doing something and
of course a party's political propaganda
but nothing realistic was in the media
and zento was there a would you say can
you assess how much of the population
would see that propaganda and the sort
of cheering of how great everything is
going in terms of harvesting or whatever
else how many people believed it in
total how many people did not believe a
word of it how many were somewhere in
between it's very hard to assess
I would say in bigger cities Baltic
states Moscow Leningrad Nelson
Petersburg all these big places
information was circulating through the
rumors it was very weird but it was the
main source of information about what's
really going on
so people were well aware nobody take
actually by that point I would say that
half of the population didn't take
serious anything what was going on our
main media because though you you who
you can see even if what whatever your
ideology is you can see that empty shops
don't match with with all these
production victories right so we had a
very huge and very successful bed of
dopes it was everybody was surviving on
jokes joke after joke and muscles in
that political you've described people
standing in lines without knowing what
the lines were for sort of under the
assumption that if there's a line it
must be worth standing in line for can
you talk a little bit about that and
also what some of those lines were four
lines can happen for everything it was
very little which was
again in Baltic States in Baltic States
you go in the shop it's sunflower oil
some canned fish or usually in again in
sample of sardines or something like
that and then bread that was no basic
minimum which was in the shops lard
probably some other things normally
people don't eat but the rest
yes rest was was queues kills kills
queues and people were killing up in in
homes at let's say
today in the butchers magazine will
appear or the delivery wine will appear
with something with meat with sausages
which maybe even salami and people are
standing for hours I remembered my
grandmother was doing full-time job just
screening shops daily she went out in
the morning and then came back in
afternoon and sometimes she came back
with something sometimes it was nothing
but but it was her daily job just to go
around shops and try to find something
and Zanta in this environment was there
trust between neighbors and the people
or was there a lack of trust in terms of
hey maybe I can get something for myself
if I report on a neighbor for example
reporting was not popular at least in
Baltic States we were a bit like it's
them and it's also reporting was not so
popular and reporting never bought you
like pilgrim of off of best venison eat
it's always was more subtle let's say if
you are a scientist and if you want to
go to the foreign friends something odd
will be linked with with your ability to
report but it wasn't very very one thing
the KGB used and it may sound really
weird today case by the Lord
Soviet lore they gay can be punished
lesbian wasn't and gays were living
normally nobody worth running after them
but if there was an end the Lord was
used to turn the gay people into KGB Wow
reporters yes that was one thing and I
think current phobia in
Russia also is a big link to is that
like let's keep gay people bad boys
right it's interesting how in
information and perception can be used
for for political means absolutely well
listen I highly recommend the book Eagle
in the fridge
it is Zenta Bryce's book about the end
of the Cold War era and the eventual
collapse of the Soviet Union Zenta
thanks so much for talking to us about
this and I'm glad we were able to make
it work thank you for I think we speak a
very happy thank you